all right so jalen hurts now a member of
the philadelphia eagles via round two
that was a surprise we had heard some
rumblings about teams that were maybe
thinking about jalen hurts and maybe
trying to make hertz a taysom hill type
of a weapon a guy who would be on the
field in different capacities for the
philadelphia eagles that may happen and
their quarterbacks coach has said in the
past he'd like to have plays with two
quarterbacks on the field at the same
time but i think primarily this is about
the idea that they understand carson
wentz
is
not that he's fragile per se he's just
he's a big rough and tumble guy who
doesn't shy away from contact so from
time to time he's going to get hurt so
they need to have jalen hurts for when
carson wentz gets hurt period
well yeah i mean i think it's more than
that too i i don't think it's just about
the quarterback situation i think they
look at it and go this guy's got
potential but this guy's a project at
quarterback mike you know he's a below
average nfl thrower he's a below average
nfl decision maker you know when you
watch him on film he doesn't want to
throw it's look at the first guy and if
he's not wide open he wants to run so
there's going to be some developmental
time as far as getting jalen hurts ready
at the quarterback position like you
know again i know we talked about this a
little earlier in the show i don't think
here here in year one if carson wentz
was gonna get dinged up or something
like that had a hurt ankle and had to
miss a game i don't think they're
looking at jaylen hurts to be the backup
this year maybe year two three and so on
but i think early on you know the point
you make about taysom hill and having an
athlete you know that can do a lot of
different things this is a guy that
could be a little h-back slot receiver
line him up in the backfield you give
him a toss sweep oh the next time we
give him the toss sweep and he might
throw the football you're going to be
able to do some creative things because
he does have a vast skill set you know
this guy's a leader he loves football
and he is strong and tough and played a
big time program so i think the value is
there i think the quarterback thing
is a little ways down the road just like
we saw with the saints and taysom hill
there's going to be some development
development you know go on with this guy
all around at the position he needs to
he needs some polish for sure
we talked on friday that the decision to
take jalen rieger in the first round of
the draft was driven by howie roseman's
belief that rieger's skill set fits
carson wentz's skill set so they they
went into round one presumably targeting
rieger i wonder chris how much they
targeted jalen hurts because we know how
this happens it can either happen just
kind of out of the blue where a guy
slides down the board brian gouda kunst
the packers gm told peter king that that
kind of is what happened with jordan
love once he made it past a certain
point i just wonder how much the eagles
intended going into the draft now after
the fact they're going to say this is
the guy we wanted all along but i wonder
how much that was part of the plan
before thursday and how much of it was
kind of something that they hatched on
the fly
yeah i got to think that it was
something that was part of the plan i
don't think you draft this type of guy
as far as jalen hurts his concern
without knowing you know you're going
into it with like a little circle around
him going man if he's there at the right
spot we want to take this football
player because we have a plan for him
you know i don't think this is totally
just about hey we're going to drop the
quarterback and see what kind of you
know see what he develops into and maybe
he can be a great you know asset for our
organization in the future so you know
this helps carson wentz certainly you
know i i guess the thing i look at with
with both of these things is you know i
wonder how long jalen hurts would have
been on the board you know jaylen rieger
at 21. man i didn't love that pick as
you know i mean i don't like any
receivers drafted in the top first round
where i ran a faster 5105 and almost ran
a faster three cone drill and it's that
guy's job in life to change directions
and do those things you know there's
some serious flaws there so you know i
know how he roseman talked about us at
the combine how we were going to support
carson wentz we want to get players
around carson wentz you know i don't
know i'm a little underwhelmed to this
point this off season about the support
they give carson wentz so uh you know i
like it but it seems like to me they're
just going hey carson we saw you carry
the team last year with not a lot of
talent we'll give you a little bit more
but we want you to carry the team once
again and um i i will see if that's
realistic or not i do think wence is
very talented and capable of doing that
type of stuff
you know i think back 12 years now to
when
the dolphins hatched the whole wildcat
thing on the patriots in 2008 and then
in 2009 when michael vick was available
to rejoin the nfl it was the eagles and
harry rosemond was working for the
eagles at the time that added vic
to the roster that was led by donovan
mcnabb now that time around
they were thinking vic could be the
successor to mcnabb because
career was pulling into the station even
though he didn't realize it but i
remember this during the preseason game
the gesture from mcnabb when they had
vic out there i just wonder how much
they're going to have hertz out there
with wentz will they put hertz on the
field instead of once will they put
hertz under center and move wentz out to
receiver like the old second quarterback
wildcat formula used to be will we see
hurts in these different things or will
it just be intended to create chaos and
you know what you go into a two minute
offense and maybe one snap hertz is
under center the next snap once is under
center and you really screw up a defense
i i i just think there's a lot of
strategizing that has gone into this for
the eagles whether or not it works we'll
see yeah but i think they have a much
much bigger plan than hurt standing on
the sideline holding a clipboard i agree
that's why i don't think it's about like
you know i've heard too many people go
like ooh should carson wentz feel
threatened no it's not about that
exactly that's what i wanted this year
on social media i just wanted to be like
yeah they didn't just pay him a hundred
million dollars to go hey we're gonna
replace you the next year with a
quarterback that's famous for running
and not really throwing the football in
fact how to leave his first school
because he wasn't good at throwing and
had to go to another one so no you're
right mike there's a plan here and this
is the school of andy reed and andy reed
is brilliant and always known how to be
creative and do different things on the
offensive side of the ball and i think
jalen hurt is going to be somebody that
like you said is going to be a weapon
for them that they're going to find ways
philly philly or dilly dilly or whatever
the hell you want to call it they're
gonna find to get find ways to get him
on the field to do things for that
offense
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports